[Musique]
donc maintenant on va se rendre sur les
temps de LED pour surveiller les abords
de la rivière et de l'État pour voir
s'il y a pas de déchets des dépôts voilà
ou des pêcheurs qui n'auraient pas
forcément le permis de pêche
bonjour
comment allez-vous
ça va ça se passe bien votre pêche
est-ce que je peux vous demander votre
permis de pêche puisque pour pêcher il
est nécessaire d'avoir un permis voilà
donc on retrouve ici le permis de du
pêcheur donc tout est valide pour lui
[Musique]
j'ai aussi travaillé avec les écoles
pour faire des sensibilisations
directement avec les écoles souvent sur
le terrain donc on a déjà une sortie qui
est prévue avec une école maternelle
autour de l'étang et le nom de la
rivière sur le thème de l'eau donc ça va
être l'occasion de sensibiliser les
enfants à l'environnement à la
protection de la planète mais aussi à
des choses concrètes comme les poissons
la faune la flore etc
[Musique]
donc en fin de journée je me retrouve au
bureau pour faire un rapport de tournée
de ce qui s'est passé dans la journée et
puis avoir un suivi à faire aussi mon
rapport sur les dépôts je suis vidé des
dépôts j'ai choisi d'être éco garde
puisqu'en fait j'ai voulu trouver un
métier qui était un petit peu plus
proche de la nature un peu plus proche
du terrain et puis j'étais aussi dans la
prévention de la protection de
l'environnement j'ai trouvé toujours été
attaché à la protection de
l'environnement et notamment de la forêt
aujourd'hui on va nettoyer la rivière
sur un petit peu plus de 2 km c'est la
distance du parcours de pêche mais il
faut savoir que la rivière est beaucoup
plus longue que 2 km donc on va pas
pouvoir tout nettoyer aujourd'hui
[Musique]